les loups les loups 4 mallette oka
déguisement je sais pas quel déguisement
il ya dans les mallettes vous allez
choisir un déguisement chacun et vous
allez devoir chanter en live ici il y a
johnny hallyday il y a mylène farmer
il ya claude françois il y à michael
jackson que les français un chirurgien
michel jacques et il y a alors on me dit
qu'à la place de johnny maître gims
c'est pareil c'est le même répertoire
vous allez choisir une mallette chacun
cette mallette il y aura un déguisement
ne sera pas sur quoi vous allez tomber
vous allez partir derrière la cabine et
vous reviendrez à chaque fois dans la
peau des chanteurs que vous avez été
désigné
grâce à la manette vous avez compris pas
nikos mon chéri mon frérot que gm est ce
que tu peux prendre
donc voilà deux comme ça c'est fait tu
la tiens là deux là deux tu parais cta
mallette je me déshabille tout de suite
je peux dire des chaussures tu es beau
comme ça à nikos tu pars avec tablettes
soirée merci pour la vidéo
j'irai moi j'aimerais bien voir nico
sans omettre guide qui prend la 4 qui
veulent à 4 non je sais pas si vous
prenez qu'elle m'allait normale à 3 l'a3
passer vos yeux pour vous allez si vous
partez avec la croix patrick c'est parti
voilà patrick pas avec la croix ça fait
plaisir aussi automonie patrick c'est
parti
et ça il m'a tuer on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya dedans oui ça y est j'ai
regardé ce qu'il peut ah oui d'accord
avec moi ce que je fais confiance à gaël
vous conseillez quoi laquelle vous me
conseiller franchement je viens de voir
la 4c pas pour vous mais cela prendra
bien soin canada je regardais ou pas non
non vous allez regarder là bas vous
accueillera et vous devrez vous prenez
laquelle mathieu de lambeaux vous partez
avec la mallette une on va les retrouver
dans un instant dans the choice
ils vont sortir on va les remettre
complètement ivre est déguisé un
complètement ou donc en maître gims ou
encore françois ou ans michael jackson
ou bien où mylène farmer
j'aimerais je suis j'en connais un mois
déjà je peux vous dire qu'ils ça on va
être bien il sort on est bien et comme
celui-là est parti on y côtoie la mairie
en quoi vous filmez mylène farmer ce
serait bien allé tout de suite on va
passer à autre chose
on va voir en quoi sont les différentes
personnes
oui oui dont je regardais le québec qui
a l'air désespéré
camille il y aura son clip dans un
instant pour le moment on va retrouver
je ne sais pas qui va sortir
on a un premier personnage qui va
chanter est ce que ça va être
michael jackson mylène farmer maître
gims ou que françois je vois les paroles
au prompteur et je pense que savoir qui
c'est attention c'est parti
première artiste de ce seuil sous
protection
m
mais bon ça lui va bien ça lui va bien
patrie fait la belle série et corse où
l'album hope afrique et progrès des
ventes avec notamment sur les joues avec
grand corps malade elle assuré dans le
corps malade est fabuleuse patrick bruel
toutou l'époque sont dessus attention
deuxième artiste je crois que c'est un
anglais parce que je vois c'est parti
deuxième partie
on
faux
à
m
l'été il était vraiment je sais pas
pourquoi ça sol de leurs mots ou mylène
farmer mais nico c'était génial mais
attention 3 ème art y est c'est parti
fabrice abadie et nice a été clément est
la mae michael jackson j étais moi
j'étais n'ayant pas et enfin bah c'est
pas une surprise qui aurait cru qu'un va
est tombé à face s'est vu milledge a vu
mylène sait quelque chose
physiquement
m
effet
oh
s
verglas
ah ouais vous vous retournez franchement
et vous êtes à fond dans le hall 1 oui
non et l'abbé a fait venir sur thierry
cuir bravo et merci tu veux jouer je
rassure les restos du coeur